okay
ah grandmaster yuri krupa again
always uh interesting games
is um rated here to 530
and i don't know close to 2600 over the
board i think
but what is he doing it's not moving and
now he's moving
okay let's um try the benko again if he
allows it
i played this couple of days ago with
two wins but i don't really um
don't really know the lines there so
this is all
all in invented over the board
okay quickly um put the knight on c4
not sure to c7 or a7 what's a proper
what's a proper square
do i have something entirely different
just uh
queen b4 this an idea just
just checking if all i could take
what is he playing after queen b4
yeah i cannot trap my queen
i don't think so
maybe this is a really silly move but
i'm curious
what what's happening
i'm threatening 94
of course first of all the knight is
hanging but
what is he doing to uh to protect it
ah queen b3 simply
okay but uh if i take on
what's the big trick after knight d5
at the end knight b6 or
or something
he cannot play knight b6 immediately if
it takes on
b4 i can i can also recapture with the
knight threatening knight c2 myself
let's see what he's up to
don't see it
knight queen b4 knight before knight b6
yeah it should be okay for me you cannot
believe this is good for white
okay guess it didn't have much choice
okay
we both um grab the rooks now
i do have something better rook
a7 is most likely complete nonsense
okay i need to i need to grab the rook
okay he's grabbing on a8 now
what what now maybe is
going for b3 bishop b2 maybe
difficult
bishop e6 maybe and then he's got the
check
okay let's develop first i cannot
cannot spend all day here
already
i already have a huge time disadvantage
knight b6 maybe this one
taking a2 with the idea on b3 just to
sacrifice them
okay night
before maybe
trying to
make more pressure on the queen side
i think a3 cannot play at all because it
gives
me this huge check and how does he
protect the queen side now
maybe bishop bishop c4
bishop c4
okay but
if i take there take c3
take a2 wow
how to cut to how to
evaluate
with little time
okay let's let's take that first
could also go for d5
okay first first check here bc
knight a2 bishop time warning bishop b2
hmm not sure
if i got enough squares there let's
let's play d5 terribly
low on time again
i should get a2 though
check
this looks rook c8 is my next
move i think trying to get the
square b3 position should be
almost winning only
really low on time again
rook c5 to come
or bishop b2 is maybe even simpler
this is this is even simpler
check
the rook should be able to get all the
pawns
check check
check
check check
check
checkmate yes nice one
yeah i think besides the
really messy position um maybe this was
just an opening mistake
not sure let's check
quickly with the computer
my computer wants to play wants to play
queen d3 here what
or e3
well this was not working
yeah black is just clearly better now
but it was of course
as usual with those strange
knights in the corner it is it isn't
entirely clear
yeah with this this should be should be
really good now
yeah he simply cannot play queen b3
maybe it was a nice try with queen
before but i'm not sure
maybe maybe just e3
really weird position yeah interesting
game at least
and a nice uh nice win i don't beat him
that often
i often get get good positions but okay
grandmaster is not so easy to
to really beat at the end you often
have a good position but they defend
very well
yeah this was was a nice one